since avengers endgame hit theaters and
since it's been out on digital release
we have learned about many different
deleted scenes some that were shot and
did not make the theatrical cut and some
that were written in the script but
didn't end up being shot what's up
everyone it's Lauren and today we have
learned about another new deleted scene
for Avengers endgame one involving
Thanos and a little node to lady death
I'll talk about this deleted scene and
how it refers to lady death and the
comics in this video quick reminder if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like the video and comment below
with your favorite superhero or villain
I'll be picking a winner for the
giveaway at 500,000 subscribers so this
new deleted scene is actually attached
to another deleted scene that we have
recently found out about we recently
found out about a deleted scene in which
2014 Thanos kills the Avengers in the
past goes back to the present and throws
Captain America skull at his feet well
as it turns out that was not all of the
deleted scene according to an interview
that Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios did with Empire magazine Thanos
had a lot more skulls than just Captain
America's in an earlier draft of this
same Kevin Feige said that one idea saw
the Avengers return from the time heist
to find that Thanos had already
overtaken 2023 earth with the big purple
guy sitting on a throne of skulls
waiting for them Kevin Feige also
revealed in that same interview that
there is actually concept art of the
scene where Thanos throws Captain
America's skull at his feet he said that
discarded scene idea where multiverse
Thanos brings Captain America severed
head and shows it to Steve there might
be concept art says Kevin Feige so this
was a scene that they fully had planned
to be in the movie but as we found out
they decided not to put it in the movie
because they thought it would be too
much for little kids so the scene would
have went the Avengers come back from
their time heist and when they get back
they find out that 2014 Thanos has
already decimated the entire earth of
2023 and when they see him he is sitting
on a throne of skulls and then he throws
the head of the past Captain America to
the feet of the present Captain America
certainly a cool scene but I can
understand why they left it out however
this scene actually pays a tribute to
death now ultimately the Russo brothers
decided to go a different way with fan
o's and not include lady
and the MCU version but we know in the
comics Thanos is obsessed with death and
there is even pictures of him from
comics of him sitting on a throne of
skulls this was going to be a little
note towards death in the MCU since the
Russo brothers decided not to include
her in the movie but ultimately this
scene got cut out
however lady death does have the ability
to bring fan oohs back to life it has
happened many times in the comics before
so perhaps we have not seen the end of
Thanos and perhaps lady death could
still make an appearance in the MCU but
let me know what you think about this
scene that never made it to the movies
where Thanos decimated the entire earth
of 2023 and was sitting on a throne of
skulls let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like the video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff